- [Reporter] Disney has canceled a plan
to build a nearly $900 million
corporate campus in Florida.
It's also shutting down a
costly new hotel nearby,
amid a high-profile
dispute with the governor.
- The days of putting
one company on a pedestal
with no accountability are
over in the state of Florida.
- [Reporter] Jacob Passy
has been covering this story
for the journal and explains
why Disney is reversing course
on two of its major investments.
- Disney was planning to
create an office campus
in Lake Nona, Florida, located in Orlando,
roughly 20 miles from the
Walt Disney World Resort.
The campus was gonna house
roughly 2000 employees,
most of whom were being relocated
from Southern California
and the campus was gonna be
about 2 million square feet,
so multiple buildings, and it
was a really huge development,
both for Disney and for Florida.
Additionally, Star Wars:
Galactic Starcruiser
is gonna be shutting down
at the end of September.
Dubbed by fans, "The Star Wars Hotel,"
this was a multi-day,
multi-night experience
where you got to live out
your own Star Wars Adventure.
It was first announced back
in 2017 and opened just last March
and cost around $350 million to build,
according to sources The Journal spoke to.
The Galactic Starcruiser experience
came up against multiple headwinds.
For starters, it was very
expensive to operate.
Unlike a normal hotel, it
had way more employees,
folks in costumes, in
characters, roaming at all times.
It was only about a hundred rooms, though.
So Disney had tight
margins on this project.
Disney cited changing economic
and business conditions
as their reasoning behind
shutting down these two projects.
More recently, Disney has announced
that they're gonna be cutting
around 7,000 jobs across the company
and shedding around $5.5
billion in expenses.
Disney is also in the
midst of a war of words
and a legal battle with Governor
Ron DeSantis of Florida.
This conflict started last
year when Disney spoke out
against the so-called "Don't Say Gay Bill"
that Governor Ron DeSantis championed.
(crowd members applaud)
- My job is not to kowtow
to some woke corporation
in Burbank, California.
My job's to stand up for
the children of my state.
- Since then, he has championed a number
of legislative moves aimed
at the Reedy Creek development,
which used to control
the land where Walt Disney
World Resort is located.
He shifted that and put in
his own political appointees
into a new board that
oversees that development.
- The corporate kingdom
finally came to an end.
(crowd cheer)
- [Jacob] In response to the changes
of the Reedy Creek district,
Disney has filed a federal lawsuit,
claiming that DeSantis and
other Florida lawmakers
are retaliating against the company
for exercising its First Amendment rights.
- I don't think the suit has
merit, I think it's political.
- These projects, were gonna
bring some high-paying jobs
to Central Florida.
Employees there were gonna be earning,
on average, $120,000 a year.
So you can imagine the
impact to local tax revenues
and local businesses that
were going to benefit
from those workers being
relocated to Florida.
- [Crowd Member] Mr. Iger.
- Disney CEO, Robert Iger
had previously committed
to investing $17 billion in
Florida over the next decade,
bringing thousands of jobs to the state.
But right now, given these changes,
it remains to be seen whether
that actually happens.
(bright music)